Hi, I'm Nick Gillespie, an editor at
large at Reason, your
source since 1968 for
everything related to free minds and
free markets.
We're in the middle of Reason's
annual webathon.
The one time, each year, we ask
our online readers, viewers and
listeners to support our
principled libertarian journalism.
We're trying to pull in $400,000 in new donations.
Your gifts are tax deductible
and go directly to funding our print
journalism, our video productions
and our podcasts.
What's more? They're being matched.
So every dollar you give
goes twice as far.
If you like what we've been doing
and what we're going to keep doing,
please give now.
Go to reason.com/donate. For
giving levels and associated swags,
some of it's pretty great.
And from all of my colleagues,
thanks!